So ALDH2 is the main regulator of the alcohol flush reaction. Let's learn a bit
more about how its turned from gene into protein. The ALDH2 gene is located on
chromosome 12 on the human genome. Chromosome
12 has about 143 million base pairs and
ALDH2 is about three quarters down the length
of the chromosome. The gene itself has 13
exons, spanning over 40,000 base pairs of DNA. After transcription
and splicing, the mRNA has 1554 nucleotides of coding
region between the start and stop codons. And after translation, there's
a protein with 517 amino acids. There's one
allele of ALDH2 that's known to associate with a severe alcohol flush
reaction and it's shown right here. What I want
you to do is use the genetic code that we
learned about in lesson three and that you can find
in the instructors notes on this page. To determine the
expected amino acid change in the sequence, and then select
the type of mutation that best describes the A allele
from the list below. Remember, if you have trouble answering
this, you should probably review some material from lesson six.